Beginning
[Silence]
at the very start of
authored by
Ali
He begins his book in the first chapter.
The way
has organized
is not dissimilar to the way that the
scholars of hadith traditionally have
organized their books of and hadith.
It's most similar to
in the sense that he will begin with a
chapter title.
In this chapter title, he will mention
whatever is to be derived from the
upcoming narrations mentioned.
Then he will mention verses of the Quran
which hold the meanings found in the
chapter title.
Then he will mention narrations
and intermittently he will define some
words in the narrations or he will
intermittently make some comments.
Though these comments are incredibly
rare, but they are there and mostly have
to do with defining certain words which
are unfamiliar
to the modern Arabic speaker of his time
because this was again 650ome
years after the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam's hij and so
just any great nation or any
powerful empire when they start to buy
and sell and expand into other nations
and mix with other cultures this will
dilute their tongue. You know, if you
think about the Muslim Empire,
when it starts to spread into
non Arabspeaking
lands, it's very common place that
they will some of the Muslim military
will settle down there. They will get
married, right? They will have children.
They will remain there because those are
the new front lines of the Muslim
empire. growing Muslim empire. Likewise
in other regions where there wasn't
any conquest military wise rather it
was just on the Silk Road for instance
connecting Asia and the you know what
is known today as the Middle East and
then on into North Africa and
Eastern Europe. We see that
You know merchants will go out into
these places. They will mix with the
people. They will marry from them. They
will marry their daughters to people
there. People will accept Islam. And
when people accept Islam and they are
non native Arab speakers, they will
bring aspects of their language
into their
into the Arabic language. So it will
dilute the it will dilute the the
language. This is common for any
language but the Arabic language is
particularly sensitive to this. Why?
Because the Quran is hinged on the
Arabic language. If we lose the Arabic
language or misunderstand it or the
ancient Arabic language spoken in the
time of our prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam begins to become cryptic to us
or begins to become distorted it will
immediately distort the meanings of the
Quran. So the Arabic language is
paramount which is why the Muslim
scholars put so much effort into
preserving the Arabic language. Not only
that, but also importing things that are
not native to that area. For instance,
let's say here in America or here in our
community here in Tucson, let's say we
imported a fruit that doesn't naturally
grow here. It grows in another country
that speak another language. When we
import that fruit, what are we most
likely going to name that fruit?
We're going to name it with whatever the
natives where that fruit comes from.
We're going to name it with that name
only. We are going to do what's called
Arabizing, right? Which in in Arabic is
called. What is? It's when you take a
non-Arabic word
and you give it Arabic letters and place
it on an Arabic scale if you will of
pronunciation. This is called Arabizing.
Right? So now I am using Arabic letters
to speak of non-Arabic words. And this
is throughout the Quran. Most of the
prophets names are Arabized. For
instance, N and
L and Ibraim and these a lot of these
names come from Aramaic. All right.
There are only four Arabic names of
prophets in the Quran which are Muhammad
Sam
and all the other names are Arabized
meaning they come from Aramaic or they
come from Persian or they come from
wherever that is imported. Good example
of this
or for instance
if we look at
the word
is a type of silk
and this silk is not native to the
people of ancient Arabia. It was
produced in Persia.
And so when they imported it before the
time of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam, if you wanted to get this kind
of fine silk, you had to import it from
Persia. And along with importing the
product, the name was imported as well.
So it was given Arabic letters. Now does
it become Arabic? Yes, because it has
Arabic letters and it has an Arabic
pronunciation. However,
it maintains its roots and etmology back
in its country of origin. This process
changes and dilutes the tongue, changes
and dilutes the language, which is one
of the big reasons why a person who
speaks modern Arabic today,
1,400 years after the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam, will they naturally
just understand the Quran. No, they will
understand some sentence structures and
obviously it's the same language so they
are a bit closer but it is very
different and so ancient Arabic has to
be learned. You obviously have a head
start over the competition over anyone
else. However, this is something that
you have to go out of your way to
actively learn. And so,
he is defining words that in the time of
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
didn't need defining. They were
commonplace. But 600 years later, these
words become less and less common and so
they need defining. 14,500
years later, we need even more defining.
Which is why of the main two functions
of writing new modern books on the same
old topics, right? For instance,
for instance, the explanation of hadith.
Why will a scholar today write a of the
Quran? There are thousands of
the reason, one of the two main reasons
is because the language has changed. And
not the language. But with language,
what changes? The way that we think.
Language is a reflection of how we
think. If you look at the Quran, it's
filled with sayings
that are familiar to the Arabs of Jah at
that time, right? Most of the parables
and examples are camels. For instance,
today, if I wanted to say there's a
huge animal, what's the biggest animal
that would come to mind?
An elephant, a whale.
What when when the when Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala says that the disbelievers
will not be permitted into paradise
until a camel walks through the eye of a
needle.
Why not a whale swims through the eye of
a needle? Why not an elephant? There are
bigger animals than that, right? This
seemingly weakens the parable. No, it
doesn't. Because the examples of the
people of that time are native to their
experience.
Today we have different experience and
those experiences
are made into idioms and sayings and
right and so this reflects the way that
we think even the way that we structure
sentences which is why it is so critical
that we never rely on translations of
the Quran because you can never fully
understand what you are hearing from
Allah. subala
you have many many people between you
and the words of Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala and so this is why noi does
this and this is why it becomes so
important today
he says in this chapter title and we
will end with this of course this is
usually five to seven minutes long 10 at
most however on you know Saturdays I
know most of us are off we're not really
in a big hurry so we could take a few
ext extra minutes especially in the
beginning here he says
so this chapter is about sincerity
and having a coherent intention
in all actions
statements
and states of being in all actions what
actions everything possibly but What's
intended here is actions that are
rewardable by Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
So good deeds in order for a person's
deed no matter how monumental or how
small it is to be eligible for
acceptance a person must have sincerity.
They must have an intention. They must
have intentionally
worshiped Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala. He
says
in all actions, speech, states of being
both inward and outward.
Basically, this is a similar definition
to that given by Islam in what worship
is. And so, a person must have a
coherent and sincere intention. The
first verse he mentions, he mentions
three verses. The first one which is the
one that we will end with today. He
says,
he says,
"And they," meaning the people of the
book before us, were commanded not
except that they worship Allah, making
sincere to him All acts of worship.
foreign.
[Silence]
the name has two meanings in the Quran.
The one that we are dealing with in this
verse is adhering to the legacy of
prophets.
So Allah is saying they were not
commanded except that they worship Allah
making sincere to him all worship
whilst adhering to the teachings of
their prophet
and that they establish salah and give
zakah
and indeed that is the righteous and
correct and upholding religion that
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala has commanded
them
We will continue with this inshall
tomorrow.
Alhamdulillah.
I do want to say one thing really
quickly. this might be a little bit
of a change
for some of us
and it's actually very different than
the
and that is that usually people confuse
a class with a motivational speech.
Knowledge isn't necessarily that which
makes you want to jump up and run out
the door and, you know, be the best that
you can be. Rather, there's a difference
between motivational speech and
inspirational speech and knowledge of
the Quran and Sunnah. And so, this will
be more knowledge based, right? Where we
will
details which that is what scholarship
is. details
and other classes or other talks or
what have you especially will take a
different dynamic inshallah it'll be
more generalized more
you know more more inspirational or
motivational if you